thank you everyone
for joining us today and i'm so excited
to hear such great presentations from
today morning
and now we are in our live q a i would
like to welcome all our guest speakers
today in this live q a session
my first question is to sydney sydney um
this was a great presentation and first
time i heard this word
productization and in this step of
productization
um which particular
um step you feel is more challenging or
where you see uh we need to spend a lot
of time
whether it is about regulation about
materials so which step is most critical
or most challenging
in productization
hi thank you thanks vivo um and
one of the things i want to thank the
organizer for
having me on this webinar today
so on this question uh if you remember
the
the the presentation we always start
with the
essay optimization um the key here is
really the when we talk about end to end
productization we we really just
start with the use case and then that
should drive
what sort of optimization we need to do
as early as possible
and therefore we have this thing called
agile iterative in other words every
time everything we do we always need to
check back
with the use use cases so the earlier
we are able to optimize
the essay for the purpose of the use
case
and the earlier we are able to get some
sense of
whether it can fulfill the performance
required
for that specific use case it can't then
um we need to be able to to pivot and to
change
um and see whether we are able to then
adapt that to
a different use case um from product
development perspective
so i would say the um you know the
important thing
is always to make sure that the
optimization is done
properly and as early as possible and
what that means is
really to see first and foremost whether
your
essay itself is reproducible
functionally
so it needs to be you you have to
imagine you have to understand that this
is
we're talking about an ibd so um
it needs to be a test that is uh that is
robust
that is something that any lab any
operator working in a lab is able to
take your instructions for use and just
follow that through
so the robustness the functional
reproducibility
the doesn't really matter who runs it it
will give you the same performance
so that those are the things when that
we focus a lot on
when we're talking about optimization of
an essay
so if you remember the anatomy of a
diagnostic test essay is only one of the
components
that's also where you need to work into
the use cases and therefore you know
what are the other components you need
to add in so
at the end of the day it comes down to
the technical performance
if i can sum up is really make sure that
you're able to get functional
reproducibility
as early as possible and
make sure that the essay itself is
robust enough before you
take the trouble to build the whole
diagnostic test around it
thank you thank thanks again uh
city there is a follow-up question and
if i go back to
yesterday's presentation so dr jerome
came
so he shared with us that the whole
vaccine process
it takes many years but new expedited
process
can get it done in um say 12 to 16
or 12 to 18 months so from a diagnostic
perspective what do you see
like uh are the tests getting expedited
uh how the regulatory bodies are
addressing
this challenge that we have this
innovative test but how to bring those
tests faster
to the public yeah
so i think from a regulatory standpoint
as as we we all know
that there are these emergency use
authorization so in singapore
hsa has something similar called
provisional authorization
so these are actually authorizations
that are given
for ibds that uh
that do not they do not um uh
they are not equivalent to a full
registration um
because uh they are just there there are
some
there are certain specifications from
regulatory standpoint that
just need to take the time and in an
emergency
setting those are those
specific technical specifications that
the regulators are
willing to say that at the point of
registration i can't give you full
registration but it's provisional
what that means is that as you are
rolling out you need to keep checking
back with the regulator on the regular
basis
and keep updating the information um
so so we we are i would say
for for diagnostics and i suppose maybe
for
vaccine and therapeutics as well in the
case of
such an emergency case
situation that most regulators are able
to deal with a
different provisional and emergency
type of a treatment of the different
samples without
a different test without compromising on
the quality
the very very basic quality management
system the very very basic how you do
your analytical verification and
clinical validation
those are basic information that
even in the emergency settings still
would need to be finished
but but time generally can be
accelerated because of
uh the um you know the the situation
where the regulators are willing to say
you know roll out and then keep checking
back with us on some of the other
details like stability data for example
which could take longer than you know
the months that we need
yeah thank you thanks dr
sydney uh i will go to uh professor
rajiv khanna
one question which is coming from the uh
audience here is
in your
research we see cmv um how do you see
corona virus and influenza
impact on transplantation especially as
the covid19
infections are increasing so much uh
is transplantation getting in fact
impacted
by this kovid19 infection and
how serious it is
professor karna can you hear us
okay maybe uh we are not able to connect
with him
so i will go to professor mishimo
uh machine was on um crisper guest three
and
christopher caspian we are uh
we are working from mark's side on these
areas for a long time
and crisper cast three look quite
exciting for both gene editing
and diagnosis from the sensitivity
perspective
what difference you see in cash 3 base
detection
versus cash 12 or cash 30.
yeah yeah thank you very much for your
question
it's you know dna editing casserole is
being edited in
enzymes so it's like cast 12
so the efficiency or like sensitivity is
equivalent to the caster
okay and uh yeah
yes so this is a question but uh like
if we bring this test are these tests
good enough
for diagnosis or do you suggest that it
will be good for surveillance or
epidemiological studies
oh yes that's a good question we are now
actually making a a crisper cast
reporting
in the faculty so we have we have to
produce a great amount of the
protein so we still waiting for that
but we checked some
we checked some some samples from the
hospital
and uh actually it's
it's it's very like adrenaline the
crispr-based diagnostic is a it's
it's very depends on the pcr
so i mean rtpcl protocols
so it's it's again also if we
if we are positive for rtpcr test
then we have the same result from by the
crisper cast three diagnostics
thanks uh thanks mashima-san um
if you can hear me you are also working
on a crisper cash
um based detection kit what are the
challenges
you see in uh getting it to the
commercialization
oh it's a that's always a good question
we have to rush
because we we haven't yet permission
from
japanese government as japanese i mean
pmda
like japanese fda we still
we are now connecting with them and we
are also
collaborating with
diagnostic companies which are making
manufacturing our enzymes so
we still need few a few months but
maybe in the winter season we we we will
have
again the pandemic change zone so
we will do it thank you
okay um one question this it's
more of uh i will not say technical but
you moved your lab from asaka to
university of tokyo
and it was during pandemic uh it must be
quite challenging for you so how
how you manage this entire thing uh
getting
uh research started again uh from one
university to another
in such a challenging situation
thank you thank you very much for
passing my partner
things so yeah it's it's it's very
challenging and you know
in this case lucky we have the two
two rough in northside university and
tokyo university
so we gradually moved from from
from osaka university to uh to tokyo
university so
we still have the lab in osaka so
in my place it's okay thank you
okay um no i i like both osaka
and tokyo so next time i am there i'm
gonna see you
thank you can you hear me
can you hear me hello
yes i can hear you uh okay that's good
yes i can okay so uh dr khanna
i'm just repeating the same question
again that um
we know infections can be the major
reason for complications
for transplantation and with the covid19
infection increasing so much across the
globe
how do you see its impact on all
transplantation related
work yeah it's been a major challenge
for particularly for stem cell
transplant
where a lot of donors who donate stem
cells are
international for example a lot of
donors in our
recipients patients who are actually
going to expecting the stem cells they
often come from
europe or germany or some other country
and those shipments have been
literally been completely cut off uh and
there's not hardly any
and you know these stem cells are coming
across and
same same thing is happening with the
organ transplant as well there's a lot
of challenge
with this covet 19 causing a lot of
delays in transplantation
um there has been push towards
moving away from allergenic stem cell
transplant to more what we call
haploidentical
where the actually the sibling or the
one of the parents actually becomes a
donor
where you've got a 50 match of the hla
so that's what
most centers are trying to develop
protocols on that and
some centers have already switched to
that other centers are
looking at that there are additional
complications of that because
triple identical being partly partially
matched
it can raise a lot of other clinical
issues for example if you don't deplete
t
cells and the b cells you can get graph
versus host disease
but if you deplete the t cells which is
absolutely essential in hyper identical
transplant
you get viral complications uh as i've
shown you a few examples in
in pediatric cases i've shown you some
of those ones
okay another question dr khanna for you
i see
is uh t cell therapy
uh it's something which started in uh
last few years
and people might not be well aware about
regulatory requirements etc
so can you elaborate around the
regulatory requirement for
t cell therapy yeah sure you know i
think the best example for that is the
the more recently approved
the novatus product which is the camera
by fda
it is a very challenging it's a hugely
challenging process because to
manufacture
any living drug so it's like you know
these immune cells are living drugs
and to deliver those from the patient or
from the off-the-shelf
uh requires a lot of regulatory
compliances and
we have a dedicated facility you have to
have
a world-class cell therapy manufacturing
suits available to you
your your regulatory in terms of quality
assurance quality control systems have
to be in place
and of course the most important part is
to be able to
um the the supply chain which is
absolutely crucial
you do not want your your raw material
to come to you at a wrong time
and and then your material when is
manufactured as a drug product
you reach to the patient at the right
time in the right place
so all the supply chain needs to be very
carefully managed
and that has taken us you know well over
a decade to streamline those things so
we have patients actually
not just in within australia but also
internationally we treat patients in
hong kong
for certain clinical trials and yeah
it's very complicated process
but in in australia the therapeutic
goods administration which is similar to
fda has given us a manufacturing license
for clinical trials
and similarly we also collaborate with
uh a biotech company in in us
tara by therapeutics they they have
built their own facility a lot of
companies are now
building their own manufacturing
capacity uh
to deliver these cell therapies for
patients so it's
it requires a lot of work
i can understand that and and people
probably want more work from you and
that's the reason i see a question
that professor khanna uh will we
be having some kobe 19 related kids from
your site
yes it's a good question in fact we have
already
we already been working on that one of
my colleague here dr corey smith
he's actually developed a whole blood uh
test for
covid uh similar to quantiferon cmv and
we can actually
um we are running that test quite
routinely now but not as a commercial
product but more as a research
reagent and you can rapidly detect
within 24 to 36 hours the
the immune competence of the patient can
be determined
uh very quickly by using similar quant
different type of assay
yes we are developing a kit for covet as
well
thank you and i uh today i
first time came to know that we are
having sherlock
as a kid coming from one lab and
detector has second lab
and kaluda from uh india from dave's lab
uh dave can you hear us
yeah i can't hear you can you tell me
yeah so i'm quite
excited to hear so many detectives
coming into the picture
but there is a one scientific question
which couple of people are asking
from you is how sensitive
is paluda in comparison to other tests
available whether it is serological
or rtpcr based test how sensitive
is your test
right so uh the sensitivity and
specificity currently are being um
matched with the gold standard uh test
which is the quantitative real-time pcr
test
um we have a sensitivity and specificity
of above 95
on saluda and this is not uh just uh
what we tested here um over almost 2 000
samples here
in uh in in in igi because we're doing a
lot of testing and we're improving
but uh now i think has also undergone
third party validation by the regulators
and i believe it's around uh more than
95 percent
in some cases we get 100 positivity uh
and close to 98 percent specificity uh
and sometimes it's around 96 percent 98
on you know two different days or
something like that but our goal was to
bring it as high as possible uh in the
process we also
learned a lot of different things uh
including
the uh you know re-look at what we call
as a gold standard
in in the field uh because uh several
qppr samples which are classified as a
positive or negative
uh give a different outcomes as well we
learned all these things during the week
it was a long
long run process but i think uh in the
end
we have a similar kind of sensitivity
and specificity
as the the gold standard pcrs that are
currently being used
okay uh dave there is a related question
and i think
um you might be able to answer that
can we differentiate between coronavirus
infection
and other influenza viral infection um
whether it is from a sentence
perspective or a detection perspective
um yes please share
so this has been done as well so it is a
hundred percent efficient in
distinguishing between corona
and other infections which are of
different similar symptoms
uh viruses but what i would like to
point here is that the principle of
detection uses uh an enzyme
which is called francis illa novicita
cas9 um
and and you know it's engineered
versions which which we made
uh this particular cast line has the
property of distinguishing between
substrates which are differentiated by
one mismatch
so uh the specificity is really nice
if you have another sequence where there
would be
you know around uh almost 90 to 95
percent homology with the target which
were anyway
taking care not to include in the design
step
but even if there is an amplification of
that kind uh
that would be differentiated by the
specificity of the enzyme itself
and added to it is that in the fellow
the step we have
we have at least three layers of
specificity added one is the
reverse transcription reaction which
occurs with the uh a gene specific
reverse primer for the sars
encoder rna transcriptome and then that
produces an rt
a cdna which is specific to the vendors
so we add another level of
specificity with a positive uh or or
a forward primer which is again specific
to that same reverse primer
and finally we have the specificity due
to the cast system itself
thanks dave i will go back to sydney
sydney um what are the various
products dxd hub is able to launch
around kobe 19 in recent past if you can
share
uh yeah so i think uh so this is uh
about the the products that dxd have had
launched uh relating to kovit 19.
okay yeah so um we have uh
so since the beginning of february
uh we have launched quite a number of
products that are directly related to
kobit 19 we started with the first one
um the first week of february we
launched
42 our it's a conventional rtpcr
product um i mean now of course
there are a lot of such conventional
tpcr products on the market
but if you think back um towards the end
of january
and the first week of february there
were very very few
such regulatory approved conventional
rtpgr
tests on the market and very very few
countries actually
are able to secure
such test kits for that diagnostic
purposes so
it's it was uh one of the uh so i i
would think that we were one of the
earlier ones that were able to
uh uh launch a regulatory approval
product which
now has uh been deployed in um i think
over 45 countries
um have regulatory approval in quite a
number of countries
um as well so uh that followed by
um c-pass so c-pass is
so maybe let me just add on 42 was a
collaboration
between a star the researcher the agency
for science technology and research in
singapore
as well as one of the local hospital
kentucksan
hospital we then followed that with
another collaboration which ended up
with the launching of
eliza test for specifically to detect
neutralizing antibodies
so this was actually a collaboration
with unus
and the company janscript jamscript the
product is called c-pass
so it is still the only product on the
market that detects neutralizing
antibodies
of course then we collaborated with a
number of other
research institutes including our
national university hospital and
university
to launch a point of care
rapid diagnostics it's a fingerprint
test for
antibodies so most recently which is the
one that i
actually highlighted in my talk was the
direct pcr test
uh that was a collaboration with a
design
defense science organization in
singapore um it's called resolute so
that's a direct pcr test that completely
is able to do away with extraction so
basically it goes directly from the
patient's specimen
into the pcr master mix and pcr so it
cuts down on
in fact not so much the tit but really a
lot of the workflow
um and makes makes it a lot easier to
deploy
you now all you need really is a
thermocycler in order to deploy
um a test like a direct pcr like
resolute
so these are the number of tests that we
have we had launched
and deployed with our partners since end
january early february
and these are specifically for
diagnostic
purposes we have also collaborated with
a number of other
private and public sector partners to
deploy
um more reagents so supporting reagents
for kobit 19 and supporting tools for
management and monitoring of patients in
the world
so these are the the different projects
that we are
we are still working on quite a number
of pipeline projects
that are looking at different use cases
so i think for diagnostics it's
important to look at the use cases of
the population
whether you're looking at symptomatic or
asymptomatic patients
that would actually drive the
performance that's required for your
essay
and how your test should look like in
terms of the product form factor
whether it is done in the lab or whether
you want the
product to be able to done in the field
yeah thank you
yeah sorry i thought i lost you yeah
no we can hear you uh-huh
yeah so so basically um that's you know
sort of sums up the
the you know some of the products that
we have launched and also the pipeline
um some projects in the pipeline that
we're working on
yeah thanks thanks again uh one thing
which
inspire me a lot is and they you used a
good word for that
kovid warriors uh when
most of the labs in academia were shut
down all of you guys were working
in your labs to bring innovative
solutions
so i just want to ask each one of you
what were the challenges
you were facing and i will start with
dave dave you mentioned that
some of the uh some of the students
researchers
got even copied positive during uh this
journey of innovation
so what how challenging it was and how
how you were keeping your lab motivated
enough to work
um during this phase um dave
yeah that's actually a very important
question we sometimes
uh you know uh put that right at the
back burner because
the the pressure and the and the
you know the uh the motivation to get
something out uh that will be helpful
sometimes dominates
the the mental health the physical
health and so on
so like i said that yes we had uh you
know
we had situations where uh the lab
members were themselves uh
getting infected we we were going and
collecting samples from
uh from areas which were you know not uh
not a very safe place to go
uh but i wouldn't call them as
challenges because we
uh we're really looking forward to to
you know finding out a solution that
could be
low cost and which could be uh effective
because
the the the asset doesn't require the
need for a quantitative real-time pcr
machine
but i think the challenge that we really
faced
uh was actually to get over the the uh
the regulatory clearances
uh and sometimes the the regulatory
clearances for
new technologies uh benchmark benchmarks
against
existing auto technologies uh makes it
really complicated to
to you know put a threshold as to what
do you qualify
as a successful approved technology
and we learned it the hard way we we
realized that you know we were
benchmarked against quantitative
real-time pcr
uh which itself uh till we did almost
you know in igiv
uh now they have probably done almost
1500 genome sequences of the
of the of the patients who are spoke to
positive and that's when we realized
that you know even the gold standard
benchmark tools
do not perform with the hundred percent
which you would need in order to
actually qualify other kids
to to to be a positive or negative you
know approved kids and so on and
we we had to do all these things we had
to do run
qpcrs with multiple kids understand what
was the variability across states
uh in order to you know improve the
essay
but more importantly to improve the
essay ourselves uh you know what are the
points which
require uh more you know how to say more
robustness
how to make it you know suitable from an
end user perspective it's always good to
have things working in the lab
but when you're thinking about a kit you
need to make it work at the end
at the hands of the user reproducibly
every single time
we needed a good partner tata sans came
up
we licensed the technology to them and
they coming from a completely different
area we needed to you know hand hold
them for days and days
and almost now almost months actually uh
to make sure that the technology is
transferred
um and i think look very good so
uh so yeah i mean we are already you
know at the moment developing or
into developing something which uh i'm
i'm really uh looking forward to
personally is to have something which
can be done almost as a point of care or
almost like a home test
uh which which is my next uh let's say
uh you know
the advancement that i'm thinking of in
terms of uh extending fellows
further thanks thanks dave uh
mashima now do you like what's your
message
to the researchers like how to keep all
the scientists
or all the students motivated during
this challenging
situation yeah keep
keep challenging that okay in my opinion
the technology scientific technology has
such such situations difficult situation
so
as as as the former
speaker said so
in in our case crystal cast technologies
it's it's very like a point of care
testing
so we can check every day everywhere
and even at home so keep challenging and
studying using anything
so good luck
thanks thanks uh professor khanna like
from your perspective what's your
message to the researchers
today look i think i mean
from my point of view we were actually a
little bit lucky you can say that we
didn't suffer that much
in terms of you know
break out here in queensland we've been
quite sort of
you know we hadn't had much
infection coming in the community
transmission has been almost negligible
um
there have been few occasional cases
here there most of them are actually
people who have traveled from overseas
so our lab actually sort of partly shut
down but we actually continue to work
in the way that what we did was we
actually divided our staff into sort of
working in the morning shift and the
afternoon shift and that really
kept the you know the work going one of
the major challenge for us
during this period was the clinical
trials that we run we were really
struggling
uh and particularly the ones we are
running in collaboration with
international collaborators
particularly in hong kong we have
literally the clinical trials have
stopped from that
and and there have been very few
recruitments um
so yeah that has been quite challenging
but i think what we have done is we've
taken
this time to focus on developing sort of
a new platform technologies and
news ideas and explore new options what
could be sort of done and coveted was
one came an opportunity to us to really
work on that and we really pushed that
program
quite hard and we have um as i said
before we have
now developed a whole blood test similar
to quantify on but we're also actually
developing
a covert t-cell therapy as well for
critical ill patients those patients who
cannot mount their own t-cell response
our goal is to actually have
off-the-shelf uh cover t-cell therapy
available for
for really sick patients who are
intensive care and need urgent
intervention immunological intervention
so that will be something quite exciting
and we're starting to develop a process
for manufacturing of those t
cells from and what we're doing is we're
recruiting these recovered patients
who have uh doing well and have no
detectable virus but they have very
strong t-cell immunity
and trying to then generate t-cells off
the shelf
from these these volunteers and use it
for the patients and match to the hla
based system
yeah thanks dr
um i will go to sydney for this last
question
like how you as well as your colleagues
or collaborators from a star and others
how do you see you guys are keeping your
teams motivated
during this time
um so actually on this one
um i i think it's uh
um for for for the teams
it's really the the common vision and
the um the commitment to
be able to see what is the impact of
what we're doing
um and that was enough
to drive everyone in fact
when very few labs were
working during the period when during
the circuit breaker for example
we continued to work we
we gave everyone an option so it was
never uh
it was never a case of um we have to
it was a case of uh uh we want to
so i think we in fact
uh people were the the everyone in the
team was not satisfied with the
with the option of uh you know coming in
every other day
um doing taking different shifts or
every other week
different team different weeks um
everyone wants to be able to come in and
accelerate the work
um all the time and um
we decided to go on shift so everyone
come came in every day
and we just did uh two shifts you know
the day shift and the night shifts and
we literally were working
around the club and
and we gave everyone a choice not to
have to do that
everybody wanted to do that it was
really
being able to see the impact of what
we're doing that was driving everyone
it was very rewarding to be able to see
um launch of uh various different
products
with different commercial partners and
how they are actually benefiting
different people
and different countries so not just
singapore but being able to
support other countries
so i also want to highlight i think some
of the other speakers that highlighted
earlier
the importance of partnership in i mean
in times of
peace and in times of needs
i think during peace time we spend a lot
of time nurturing different partnerships
and those that come in really really
um uh you know handy in critical times
when we are able to really activate our
partnership
uh to be able to accelerate some of this
work
dxc hub being a really a public entity
we rely on our commercial partners
when it comes to really commercializing
and deploying some of the products that
we work with
together with them and i think
especially for diagnostics tests
where it is really something
that you need to continuously improve
um you once you launch it is not just
it's not an event it's not a transaction
it is actually
a continuous process so you launch a
product you get the user feedback and
then you come back and you improve and
then you do a
improved version so because of that
iterative nature
of of diagnostics test
having a good relationship with your
partners
is extremely important to be
able to continuously have that
relationship so that you can
continuously improve
with your partners in terms of the
products that you push up together with
your partners to the market
it's something that i feel also has
had worked really well for us
thank you thanks sidney uh this was my
last question
i just want to thank dave you sydney uh
uh and professor khanna for
uh exciting discussion i can tell you
two things from my side uh
my respect for researchers increased
substantially during this kobe 19
uh pandemic i can see people working day
in day night
to bring new innovation so i just want
to
thank on behalf of mark not only to four
of you but also to
all the people who are working in your
labs students postdocs
as well as your collaborators because of
whom you are able to bring such great
work
to our audience today thank you everyone
and we are looking for our audience to
join our next session on
therapeutics and vaccine development
related
to infectious diseases thank you
everyone
thank you thank you